[Música]
olá pessoal
pra mim é um prazer muito grande estar
aqui com vocês hoje
foi aqui que me formei em engenharia fiz
o mestrado
depois veio o doutorado eu preciso
confessar que eu passei meus últimos dez
anos de vida desenvolvendo pesquisas e
projetos de consultoria para ajudar as
empresas a serem melhores para o mundo
de hoje
eu vim aqui falar pra vocês sobre como a
gente pode cuidar de um jardim melhor
mas antes vou explicar o porquê
assim como na natureza os nossos
relacionamentos as nossas organizações
ea sociedade de uma maneira geral são
formados por sistemas complexos são
sistemas complexos porque são formados
por pessoas por uma rede de pessoas que
se relacionam interagem todos os dias e
cada uma dessas pessoas traz a sua
própria bagagem de vida para este
sistema e essa bagagem pelo repleta de
experiências de crenças e valores que
muitas vezes são diferentes ou
complementares aos demais pessoas
portanto os nossos relacionamentos as
nossas orientações ea sociedade forma os
sistemas complexos e quando nós olhamos
para as organizações
existem pelo menos dois tipos de
sistemas
o primeiro sistema é formado pelas
organizações que têm o olhar de explorar
o meio ambiente são a orientações que
têm foco única e exclusivamente e um
grupo de atores daquele sistema
no caso os acionistas são as empresas
que buscam gerar o máximo retorno
financeiro possível no curto prazo para
seus acionistas
essas empresas são feridas numa forma de
comando e controle
o outro sistema de de orientações é
formado pelas organizações que possuem
uma orientação para atender e cuidar
muito bem das necessidades das
diferentes pessoas com as quais elas se
relacionam sejam os acionistas os seus
fornecedores
os seus colaboradores os clientes os
seus parceiros de negócio o meio
ambiente ou à sociedade de maneira geral
essas empresas entendem o seu propósito
maior e busca impactar positivamente o
meio ambiente no qual elas estão são as
organizações que geram impacto econômico
social e ambiental
essas organizações tendem a ter uma
olhar de longo de longo prazo
elas buscam cuidar das próximas gerações
que estão chegando e eu gostaria de
fazer um teste
agora aqui com vocês dessas organizações
qual delas que vocês gostariam de
trabalhar quem gostaria de trabalhar na
primeira organização levante a mão por
favor é dá pra ver que ninguém levantou
a mão aqui e quem gostaria de trabalhar
no segundo tipo de organização por favor
levantei a mão é dá pra notar que
praticamente a sala inteira levantou a
mão e é interessante é que nós estamos
cheios de millenium aos que preferem
trabalhar nas organizações desse segundo
o sistema ou de sistema b
vocês agora acabaram de reforçar três
resultados de pesquisa que eu tive nos
últimos dez anos
o primeiro resultado é que aquele grupo
de organizações que têm uma lógica de
explorar o meio ambiente de comando e
controle
essas organizações tendem a ter uma taça
uma alta taxa de insucesso das suas
iniciativas estratégicas
eu analisei mais de mil pesquisas no
mundo todo em países como austrália
estados unidos china e brasil
identifiquei que cerca de 60 a 90 por
cento das mudanças daquelas organizações
tendem a falhar no longo prazo a
principal causa é que elas estão
buscando explorar o meio ambiente e não
colaborar com o meio ambiente
na contra mão essas organizações que
buscam vivenciar um propósito
maior elas tendem a gerar uma satisfação
seis vezes superior para todos os seus
stakeholders para todas as suas pessoas
com as quais elas interagem
neste momento estou avaliando 1.115 das
maiores e melhores empresas do brasil
estamos encontrando aqui na usp um
seleto grupo de empresas que gera um
impacto positivo no seu meio ambiente
são empresas como a reserva a natura o
boticário hospital albert einstein
a fazenda toca a jacto são empresas que
vivenciam seu propósito e gera um
impacto positivo para todas as pessoas
com as quais elas interagem
nos estados unidos o professor rádio
episódio encontrou o mesmo grupo de
empresas são chamadas empresas
organizadas e lá elas geram retorno aos
seus acionistas
nove vezes superior à média das demais
empresas então vocês acabaram de
reforçar todas essas pesquisas são
feitas no mundo todo
um terceiro dado que gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês é que essa grande
transformação que está em curso no mundo
dos negócios
vai vir com o fortalecimento dos
milênios no mercado de trabalho
hoje os milênios já estão questionando o
significado de sucesso dos negócios
e olhe analisando os dados do ipea é o
projeto que até 2030 os milênios vão
representar 63 por cento da força de
trabalho aqui no brasil
se hoje os milênios estão abrindo a sua
startup se hoje eles estão começando a
ocupar alguns cargos de trainee nas
multinacionais até 2030 sua startup
teriam decolado
eles estarão ocupando os cargos de
liderança gestão dessas multinacionais
será um momento que nós teremos uma
grande transformação do mundo dos
negócios e para que essa transformação
sejam mais positiva possível
só falta uma coisa é importante que
todos nós tenhamos consciência dessa
complexidade que é o sistema
organizacional e tenhamos consciência de
como nós podemos agir para ter o impacto
mais positivo possível para poder ajudar
as pessoas a fazerem isso eu descobri um
experimento que qualquer pessoa pode
fazer na sua casa ou no seu apartamento
junto com a minha esposa e nós moramos
num apartamento
nós resolvemos construir um jardim
nós compramos as madeiras cortamos as
madeiras preparamos toda a estrutura de
um jardim vertical na seqüência nós
compramos alguns vasos de fibra de coco
para que o caráter mais natural e
orgânico possível
compramos algumas moedinhas vamos
plantando essas mudas
no início nós tentamos plantar as mudas
mais diversificadas possíveis tem ali um
ato como antúrio orquídea bromélia
algumas ervas como cebolinha salsinha
manjericão e com o tempo eu fui me
desenvolvendo pra aprender a cuidar
daquele jardim todos os dias logo no
início eu cometi algumas falhas que eu
vou compartilhar com vocês
a primeira é que eu chegava do trabalho
à noite e aguarda as plantinhas e não
era bom está enxergando elas eu descobri
logo nos primeiros dias que eu teria que
colocar água nelas
logo pela manhã para aproveitar a maior
atividade metabólica que elas existem
durante o dia também foi descobrindo que
nem todas as plantas precisam de águas
todos de água todos os dias
algumas das plantas precisam de água a
cada dois dias outras uma vez por semana
eu fui descobrindo também que conforme o
meio ambiente muda
eu tenho eu teria que mudar a forma como
estava cuidando das plantas
nos dias que chove elas precisam de uma
quantidade menor de água nos dias que
faz sol mais forte elas precisam de uma
quantidade maior de água
descobri também que quando pega um fogão
em uma das plantas
eu tenho está observando o mais rápido
possível aquele fato pra cuidar bem
daquela pontinha que se não cuidar bem
dela
existe uma interdependência do sistema o
fogão pode pegar as outras plantas com
resistência menor ele pode matar aquelas
outras plantinhas no início várias
plantas morreram algumas eu tive que
doar o meu pai no jardim foi evoluindo
evoluindo e eu fui aprendendo com esse
processo e agora gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês sete edições
que nós possamos cuidar melhor das
nossas organizações dos nossos jardins e
da nossa sociedade
a primeira lição tem a ver com o fato de
que cada planta ela é singular
cada planta tem necessidades de água e
de sol diferentes
e o mesmo acontece nas organizações cada
pessoa é singular nas organizações
cabe aos gestores as lideranças
observarem reconhecerem isso e atenderem
às necessidades de cada uma das suas
pessoas
a segunda lição é que a qualidade do
meio faz toda a diferença nas plantas
isso tem a ver com a qualidade do solo o
solo tem que os nutrientes necessários
para que elas possam crescer nas
organizações têm a ver com a qualidade
dos nossos relacionamentos
as pessoas têm que criar um ambiente
positivo onde as próprias pessoas possam
aprender e crescerem juntas o terceiro
aprendizado tem a ver com se observar os
sinais que vêm do ambiente
nos dias que faz sol a gente em colocar
mais água nos dias que chove uma
quantidade menor de água
o mesmo acontece nas empresas dependendo
da mudança que acontece no ambiente
externo as empresas têm que se adaptar
tem que aumentar o ritmo dos seus
projectos ou até mesmo mudar o escopo
das suas iniciativas
a quarta edição é que existe um
equilíbrio sistêmico na natureza cada
planta o meio ambiente e os seres que
interagem com elas estão em pleno
equilíbrio
o mesmo acontece nas organizações
existe um equilíbrio de troca sistêmicas
entre diferentes pessoas que interagem
com cada sistema organizacional e se
essas trocas não estão equilibradas
a tendência é que as mudanças fazem no
longo prazo por exemplo não adianta a
gente querer melhorar melhorar a
experiência de compra dos nossos
clientes ou dos nossos pacientes se for
um hospital
se nós não trabalharmos a experiência
dos nossos colaboradores a qual é o
quinto aprendizado é que a diversidade é
uma força no meu jardim se eu tivesse
plantado um único tipo de plantinhas
a tendência é que eu poderia ter perdido
todo o jardim ao longo do tempo
o mesmo acontece nas organizações a
diversidade
pensamentos ajuda as empresas a
reduzirem os riscos e aumentarem a
probabilidade de sucesso das suas
iniciativas
a sexta edição é que existem ciclos
evolutivos naturais cada planta tem o
seu tempo natural para favorecer o mesmo
repete nas nossas organizações
muitas vezes os gestores querem acelerar
o ritmo das mudanças ou querem
implementar iniciativas que as pessoas e
que a própria organização não está
preparada para aceitar naquele momento
pois existem níveis de maturidade
diferentes e nós temos que reconhecer
los e respeitá los
a sétima edição aprendida é que a
qualidade dos resultados do jardim
depende da qualidade ou da condição
interior do jardineiro e nas
organizações a qualidade dos resultados
gerados depende da condição e da
qualidade interior dos líderes e dos
gestores
se eles não estiverem preparados um grau
de consciência mais elevado sobre aquele
sistema no qual eles estão inseridos
a tendência é que as mudanças fazem
longo prazo ea tendência é que o impacto
gerado não seja positivo
através dessas sete missões eu pude me
desenvolver enquanto pessoa enquanto
jardineiro e hoje o meu jardim ele ocupa
a parede inteira
todas as pessoas que vão em casa ficam
maravilhadas com jardim a uma das coisas
mais bonitas do meu apartamento pra mim
é um prazer enorme
acordar cedo todos os dias e observar as
plantas entender como elas estão regá
las e todos os dias eu levo a minha
filha de quatro meses para poder tocar
para poder sentir a natureza
aos poucos eu vou desenvolvendo
ensinando ela sobre a complexidade do
mundo e sobre como nós podemos nos
prepararmos para sermos pessoas melhores
e podemos cuidar do nosso próprio jardim
eu acredito se cada um desenvolver essa
habilidade
cuidar melhor dos seus relacionamentos
nós podemos criar um mundo muito melhor
e talvez a partir de agora todos nós
defensivos olhar os nossos
relacionamentos as nossas organizações
ea sociedade como se fosse um jardim que
basicamente precisam ser cuidados todos
os dias por nós
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]